hi guys so today I've got truth for you
it's flappy bird you know have you heard
a fluffy bed it's this game ya know
you've all heard a flatbread my friend
actually still got on our iPod I never
actually played flappy bird because I
get really angry at games like that she
was like well I've got a score of 28 if
you can beat it so the competitive side
of me was like yes okay so let's go oh
oh wait it starts like straight away
don't hurt that this game is super
addictive I don't understand personally
for me why people would want to play a
game that they just um I God the Holy
just can't even get past the third Pole
I do like how the birds change color
then but then you kind of think why they
change colors that because you're coming
each Brad why is it so impossible I
actually wasn't gonna play flappy bird
because I hate games like this that just
I'm doing it make you feel like you're
doing okay and I oh Jesus Christ sug
surely I'm like worse than everyone
else's everyone can't be this bad right
what kind of breed of bread is this
where his mouth is bigger than his wings
no wonder you can't fly properly I don't
wanna carry on plane hmm Jesus cries I
just I use hate these games cuz i get so
they're just annoying but this just
there's no words to describe omit 5670
ah it lulls you into a false a false
sense of security yeah and that's your
putters talking to you I can actually
totally see how people get hooked on
this because you hate it and you're like
yeah after this one I'm definitely gonna
put the game down because it starts and
there's suddenly start doing well and
you're like I'm like a genius like now
look at me oh my god aah 10 I think it's
based on where oh I can't talk and play
I think it's based on where the pipes
are like oh my gosh like that should
have been easy but I'm just an idiot
like if they're near each other the gaps
Senate no to Brad Oh where's my favorite
color we can do this oh I want to give
up already again now my happy streak is
gone I can't get past 10 how did I even
get to Jen that's ridiculous I didn't
even touch it I swear I going tapped it
and it just didn't wear it as gainful if
it weren't for these pipes then this
bird would maybe one day down how to fly
like a proper bed and he wouldn't keep
on dying my everyone is the start of
this game surely like it feels like I'm
the only one that's about oh maybe
that's the way that the game wants you
to fill in what should make you feel hey
this is easy you're the only one that's
bad and then you kind of want to prove
to the game like no I can do this I just
want to get to 10 and at least then I
can oh then I can beat my own score with
Ted felt bad though is it for fluffy bed
I listen I don't know when I was told 28
is the score Sabine I was like
28 so easy and I'm like I think he'll be
lucky if I get 14 one more time gonna
get past two one more time i get past 21
1 more time going to get past it I to
tell your purse to a sec oh my gosh okay
right haha screw it i'm not playing that
anymore i don't even care they didn't
beat the high school I don't even care
that you guys probably think I suck
because hey everyone sucks at flappy bro
right that's what I'm telling myself ah
to be honest I'm not that fast that it's
been taken off the play store because
I'm definitely not neither playing that
game again why would not have it on my
phone and don't understand ways fun to
you guys but it is so did I have fun
with your fluffy bread hope you enjoyed
don't forget to leave a like if you did
and have lovely day or evening bye